à l'aide alors salut qu'est ce qui se
passe selon les premiers témoignages
attentats à la bombe dont bientôt quatre
de vos agents et 5 passes en quelqu'un
revendiqué l'attentât on a trouvé ça
vous croyez qu'elle est morte
on ne l'a pas retrouvée dans la bande il
y avait des traces de chrome
on n'avait pas vu ça depuis les puis
paris l'horloger a remis ça abbott est
toujours vivante jacques en cours
n'ai pas le choix le président exige des
réponses
je crois que c'est toi qui a tenté de le
donner
tu sais bien que j'ai rien fait à bazet
cette fille est un atout extraordinaire
alors pour quelle raison est elle
toujours en fuite
il faut que j'accède à l'heure
agua également de marie ya pas de grands
moyens 5 fichiers ont été supprimés
c'était le code d'accès d'abord si
jamais vous la croisez n'hésitez pas une
seconde
au nom de code et l'horloger c'est un
des tueurs à gages les plus recherchés
au monde
ce terroriste ait récupéré à tallinn
on n'a pas à douter de nos meilleurs et
plus fidèles agents et les lâchers
honteusement au moindre problème
il faut qu'il arrête